nuovo episodio
indovinati paura o da con nuovi
personaggi
nell'occorso video challenge indovina
chi paurosa vi ho detto se vuoi torino
16 mar i carabinieri ora tutto questo
come promesso ecco qua un altro episodio
ma abbiamo anche aggiunto nuovi
personaggi che scoprirete fra poco ma
prima di te questo video supera gli
11.000 mi piace si farà ancora un altro
episodio male
le regole saranno un pochino diverse e
cioè se non indovina il personaggio il
personaggio salirà quindi lasciate un
bel mi piace perché sarà ancora più
pauroso e divertente ma la prima di
iniziare mettetevi comodi prendete i pop
corn e che la sala igiaba inizia circa
la forbice forbice e altra forbice sardi
appunto il punto i lunghi ma hai sempre
perdonato
abbiamo il personaggio di
ok io lo so beh certo che tu però non lo
devo tutto deciso
qual è la tua prima domanda tu
personaggio per caso gli occhi neri no
non ha gli occhi neri allora con gli
occhi neri sicuramente dagli aghi poi
occhi neri anche chi si messi poi che
c'è anche con gli occhi neri vediamo il
gelataio
molte morti non lo so se gli occhi neri
volte ma latino baldi agli occhi neri si
è anche agli occhi neri poi chi c'è
anche voglio finire tabula il pd c'è un
occhio nero e uno rosso vabbè lo
lascerei e slider ben non ha gli occhi
malefica che
donano agli occhi neri car toccata agli
occhi neri ma anche lupo gli occhi neri
e poi chi altro agli occhi neri e basta
male però passate c'è un bel po di
caselle toccante adesso a mi sono
dimenticato di dirvi ovviamente voi
provate a indovinare chi è il
personaggio prima di vitale quindi
provatevi opinare qual è il mio
personaggio prima di vitale e provate
indovinare quale personaggio di vitale
prima gara indovini io potete provare a
indovinare il giorno i commenti e ora
tocca a me allora il tuo personaggio a
tutti i denti credo di sì sembra di
vedere tutti i denti si al piano quasi
tutti e guardino tutti quasi così tutti
ok allora togliamo tutti i personaggi
che non hanno i denti quindi gelataio
non ha i denti il grinch non credo che
abbia i denti perché non si vedono e
baldi non hai detti voldemort non mi
ricordo si celi ai denti perché me lo
ricordo che erano frutti dei suoi denti
blend perdono ai denti perché non ha
neanche la bocca a chi non ha i denti
non sceglierlo voce lea car toccate né a
tantissimi di denti anche visto il
mitici leo e malefica ce li ha non male
il personaggio ha per caso i capelli
biondi prima di rispondere non vi ho
detto un'altra cosa s'è sentito il
rumore strano di sottofondo tipo 1
sgranocchio continuo e berlino qua
dietro che grano qiando i suoi
giocattoli
[Musica]
no non ha i capelli biondi ai capelli
biondo questi qui ma che belli biondi
c'è la moglie di giochi
che hanno buttato giù che non me ne sono
reso conto che era via moltissima leva
su internet ma caracciolo stile
intermedi un brutto
poiché è altro gioco beh
non si sono più alte bionde ma l'ho
fatto non ci posso credere alle
sopracciglia alle sopracciglia e dire sì
alle sopracciglia le sopracciglia lo
slider non ha le sopracciglia volti a
morte da una le sopracciglia benevento è
nato il lupo mannaro onorare
sopracciglia grechi non avete francilia
loro c'hanno carlton calcio non alle
sopracciglia il nonno promuove
sopracciglia bene aspetta che odi
guardino alle sopracciglia enovitis
esiste
wow ho fatto una domanda bellissima
guardate quanti personaggi ha eliminato
papa voi avete indovinato chi ha vitale
non siamo molto vicini comunque se sono
in vantaggio di un paio di castellino
papaya vedremo vedremo
se lo domanda mia domanda è il
personaggio è un personaggio peloso
si è un personaggio pericoloso però
aspettavo ma io guardo perché dire pre
lowes e diverso da dire è coperto tipo
di pelliccia perché ad esempio anche
mister miti potrebbe essere peloso
vabbè potrebbe avere tutte le braccia
pelose
ratio era quindi la domanda l'ha già
fatta e qui che anche lo nei bar
potrebbe essere molto penoso e anche
specifici
anzi secondo me scariti terrebbero
quindi dovevi fare le domande ed i due
vi dire alla pelliccia è invece detto e
veloso e quindi anche gli esseri umani
possono essere pelosi ti conviene non
eliminare anche scheri teacher che
secondo me molto pelo quindi ti sei
sbagliato domanda ma effettivamente ha
chiuso numeroso però non ho la pelliccia
rappresentano timore più timore ho
trovato un personaggio che non è però so
sicuramente lo slider designer non è
penoso non posso abbassare però aspetto
anche picchi pd chi non è pelosa
sembra venosa picchia forte fonte morto
non è però
ha abbassato mister mit secondo me c'è
il curry roberto
vuol dire che sono in vantaggio io ci
sono 10 caselline tuo tour etico
la mia domanda per questo round e
diciamo agli occhi chiari attenzione non
ho detto che i celesti occhi verdi o che
buon hockey grigio detto chi chiare
quindi potrebbero essere tutti questi
colori quindi secondo tre anche i
crediti agli occhi chiari che ci sono
degli occhi bianchi e in effetti bianco
e un colore chiaro questi anche il
bianco a picchiare agli occhi chiari
facesse bene allora possiamo eliminare e
ibaf redditi che colore elio che non lo
so perché sono freddi e gli occhi freddi
saranno tedeschi non lo so penso che
frediano via gli occhi chiari anche
sulla piece la via gli occhi verdi
annabella gli occhi chiari anche joker
anche la validità che dracula agli occhi
neri quindi non possiamo eliminarlo e lo
nego agli occhi verdi mister mezzo agli
occhi marroni malefica gli occhi celesti
lupo gli occhi scuri
e scherzetti che colore ha gli occhi non
assumo ne rimangono pochi
quindi qual è la tua domanda il
personaggio alla pelliccia
non è cambiato
ora stai attento e non chiedi più te
però faceva la pelliccia ebbene sì
all'appello alla pelliccia possiamo
eliminare scrittice il joker in questo
latte che abbiamo il nonno
malefica e l'oro ei
poemi
mister kit quindi
maturo sono due non ci credo vitale
vincerà nel prossimo round se io non
faccio una domanda molto molto preciso
dovere una domanda che elimini tutti i
personaggi praticamente bene lasci solo
uno ma è impossibile
ho un'idea il tuo personaggio è una
bambola e va bene sia una bambola ok
allora possiamo eliminare kiri teacher e
aspetto momento pre di una bambola
sotto la sabbia è un animatronic non è
una bambola ecco eliminiamo joker e il
milione e mia politica ormai altre
bambole qua la moglie dei giochi
annabelle laffi non vincere un biner
l'ora con il prossimo round di tempo tra
indovinare chi
allora qual è la tua domanda finale il
per caso di colore verde eh no non è di
colore verde quindi quale l'altro
personaggio che hai quindi se non è di
colore verde e noi possiamo abbassare il
grinch non ci resta che il tuo
personaggio è per caso il lupo mannaro
graham indovinare qual era il suo cranio
annabelle no drappi si no
voi siete riusciti a dominare personaggi
e di evitare il mio personaggio ma ora
passiamo al secondo round and round
merlino sta suggerendo chi deve
scegliere a
berlino vantato un ottimo suggerimento e
chi vi ha detto mourinho ha detto che
tocca ovviamente
il reato però sto scherzando non è
quello che ho scelto tante insieme
diciamo sapevo io ho scelto il
personaggio ed un chilo di
carta fuori gioco
il tuo personaggio e un cappello
no non ha il cappello malefica un
cappello freddi un cappello quindi lo
eliminiamo poi gennaio anche mi sa che
un cappello nov i gelatai o il cappello
da taglio il cappello che basta tutti
gli altri non hanno i capelli ok tocca a
me allora il suo personaggio ora la
pelle liscia 6 alla pelle liscia
allora non può essere a di maghi o devo
dire che baldi alla pelle liscissima non
può essere il grigio neanche freddi non
può essere neanche questi vizi non era
pelle lo slide barchino questo è uno
slider
il gelataio non lo so il lupo mannaro
non può essere non può essere neanche il
lupo è neanche cartoon cat perché non ha
la pelle wow mio eliminato il sacco qual
è la tua domanda allora il passaggio
alle orecchie
bestie certo che alle orecchie ma tutti
i personaggi mi sembra che abbia le
orecchie poi ho capito forse tu volevi
chiederete alle orecchie non umane ma
ormai fatto la domanda quindi ti dico sì
perché ad esempio il grigio non c'è né
amore che è anche lo sbaglia dalle
orecchie a chi vuol chicchissimi silice
le amo chiede non al business leader
vernon alle orecchie è vero in una mia
che naso la bocca gli ho mai visto e poi
basta così perché tavolo sono quelli che
non sono le orecchie bene ora che
eliminino su quelli sensori che la mia
domanda è il suo personaggio ha qualcosa
in mano quindi potrebbe essere un'arma
un oggetto
nell'acqua cosa in mano qualcosa baldi
sicuramente sa qualcosa perché il
righello critici non ha niente in mano e
il joker ha le carte in mano quindi
nostri giochi gelata io non ho niente
voglio marcano niente la bella la niente
niente l'unico non ha niente granny alla
bassa picchia la mazza la voglia di
sacchi e non sa niente e non ariete
mister mit non è niente male vi
cavalieri
mi rimangono poche
come pace fare un'ottima domanda per
essere in vantaggio il tuo personaggio
alle orecchie animali
ho fatti ho dato un suggerimento prima
per le volate a liriche animali
sicuramente non il gioco che neppure
schieri teacher e neanche voldemort
latte baldi non c'era proprio lecce
pinky si potrebbe dracula no il nonno no
il lupo si carlton cup si e lo dico no
devenuto moglie di sacchi mister mister
che da bello
rimasti 66 contro 4 questa è una sfida
all'ultimo cattivo garros dobbiamo fare
un'ottima domanda allora il tool
personaggio sorride allora sorride è un
personaggio cattivo non sorrido allora
non può essere joker perché gioca sta
sorridendo baldi alla faccia in giù
merlino star c'erano chiedo l'ossicino
pighi non si sa di e sorride ma non
sorride perché non si vede la bocca e
grandi decisamente non sorride quelli
sono arrivate tre vantaggi
sia il tuo personaggio e rosa
o no il mio personaggio è rosa non siamo
idonei oppure si era notata solo ce ne
siano tanti rotta
queste rose ha detto no questo no
il lupo non è rosea carlton cat non è
rosea abbiamo solo chi si messi che è
rosa e picchi e 2a 3a tappa o no credo
ad ovada ho un'idea invece di fare una
domanda proverò ad indovinare adesso
perché ero sicura che abitano nel
prossimo turno vincerà perché solo due
personaggi quindi proverò buttarmi e di
indovinare il volto di allora secondo me
e lei è secondo voi il tuo personaggio
e graham i no
[Applauso]
il tuo personaggio
ha per caso una mazza in mano a una
mazza quindi io spero che tu li ai
grammy e pighi così non saprei quale
eliminare delle due o questo personaggio
più vecchie ssis
significhi
adottati in blu
piace nemmeno a chi
[Musica]
ha vinto entrambi torni vitale ma se
volete una rivincita e lato momento è
personaggio quale era quindi e provate a
indovinare dalla sinistra ne sono
rimasti due o no ma ieri ho già chiami
migliore al termine proprio hub ricorso
sara
baldi e granny gremi l'aveva tolta c'era
pighi e baldi quindi balzi sì avevo
scelto baldi e voi avete indovinato fa
purtroppo non avevo indovinato bassa
come rimpiazzo se volete una rivincita
se non avete visto di altri episodi sono
super super super diventai di pila sono
le caselline qua per andarli a vedere
cliccate su quella che preferite